when we met pixie she had just undergone
a controversial procedure to remove six
ribs to get a 14-inch waist
we also met her surgeon here's our story
i always been inspired by
mental health
you're bringing me state you're bringing
stigma to mental health stop no stigma
no none no stigma
mental health
body dysmorphia
mental health
it's okay
it's okay
you could prep press play
but firstly let me take a second and
look i leave look at this
a lot of images in your head in it this
is a whole new one
i'm not gonna [ __ ] with y'all this is a
whole new level
the worst part i'm on a new level she's
wearing a corset too yeah to make a
slimmer
huh so you already removed the ribs and
you're doing a corset yeah a waist
trainer your waist ain't training [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is it's okay it's
okay if we talk about it freely without
shame
we'll overcome it
mental health
it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's not even trying to laugh
at or whatever it just is what it is
it's fine
but who is she hurting i'm pretty sure
she has a banging instagram account and
not everybody that's following her is
following her for the right reason
who is she hurting that
my image it's [ __ ] up that people that
are subjected to
to
oh my god that beauty stand there is yet
you're part of the beauty standards i
got [ __ ] on my instagram
talking about both things love love love
who you are love what you are love love
love love i love love love love love do
all them surgeries and [ __ ]
yeah
you're the victim in the product
you're the murder person and the knife
you're the target and the gun
you're both
you're both
yeah you're the perpetrator and the
victim
both
which are you both them
b-o-f-f-u-n bow
mental health at this point
today he has chosen i chose violence
today i don't want peace i want violence
mental health
it's fine
it's really fun but
crazy can i ask you guys oh go ahead in
this body positivity movement yes do you
think that when she risked her whole
[ __ ] life to remove her ribs she felt
positive
about her body she doesn't care she
survived
she survived she don't give a [ __ ] you
know what's better than being body
positive body sensible
how about that [ __ ] talk about
positivity and they just they just
remove it's like being it's like i'm
zero like i'm zero like what it is uh
where they don't they don't they don't
do any garbage they don't edit
in french you know when they don't
produce any garbage you know they don't
ever produce anymore like they don't
they find a way to never produce it but
some of you people are zero garbage but
really are just keeping all the garbage
inside
so your house is full of
filled with garbage
you're not solving the problem you're
full of garbage so when you're doing
that body positivity body posit
i understand the purpose and why some of
y'all
are [ __ ] up my g
and are not solving any issues right now
we have taken time to do a little
research
to find out
what women do in the privacy of their
surgery
and we have discovered that they are
doing this thing called rib removal
it is where a doctor goes inside their
body
and removes the ribs
not the ones that you eat
but the ribs inside your body
they remove them
and then you look like photoshop
like like somebody come in they edit
and you look ridiculous
and we have seen this thing we ask
ourselves for what reason and you look
like anime we don't want this it is a
sickness it is defiant therefore we
don't want
for what reason you remove this
now you look like jello
we don't want
she left me she left the office today
she said
i am a human being she returned she says
i am two triangles
don't even lie i said two triangles
the knowledge has entered your cranium
it is quite wise
i saw it like that that was bars
okay wait wait
maybe i um
your rib cage
is meant to hold in your organs
correct
yes to protect your lungs to protect
them liver all that stuff you know i
mean maybe not liver but yeah okay
so now it's just kind of like
no maybe not maybe they just did a
little cup like that and then she has
small organs and then they replace that
[ __ ] they remove they rearrange that
maybe that's what it is i don't know the
procedure doesn't matter so let's say
hypothetically i'm [ __ ] her from the
back
do i have to be careful how much i
i just hold on to her hips i guess i
don't know ask her
i told you there was a image running
through your head there's a lot of
images
i said what is a human without a rib
cage i just never thought of that you're
just seeing him right now
he doesn't have no ribcage she removed
three so she still have some
because the upper ones
is aladdin showed up on my balcony and
he said get on
i can show you the world a whole new
world
no thank you
don't make it you don't want to see a
whole new world no no no i want to be
the hunter back of notre dame staying in
my tower cartoons all the curves and
tiny ways i'm really happy with how i
look now but i still see things that
could be fixed
getting my ribs removed i have been
thinking about for a long time it's
always been like a dream of mine
it's really hard to find the surgeon
almost impossible the only reason why i
can do it now is because and you know
what one thing we also have to admit
with this whole body positivity you'll
ever notice that these surgeries never
stop at one
you never notice that when you start
down this alley it never stops
there's always more you can do
and
maybe i'm wrong most of the people i've
seen have a minimum of two if they get
one done they get in botox they get lip
fillers they and nose again some else
done if not then as they start to age
like you know what i don't like these
wrinkles let me edit
let me edit
i know this
i know this video is already on youtube
and people have watched it a million
times but let me edit the video
and i think there's not enough
discussion about like how these two
things like really contradict themselves
whole body positivity and this whole
[ __ ] like i just
i've never bought it i understand people
like well love your body however it is
so you love your body
now that you've gotten the surgery
why couldn't you love it before oh are
you are you trying to tell me to lie
that you loved it the whole time that's
why you put your life under
come on bro
come on bro what about even these
[ __ ] silicone titties
how many people are getting like
diseases from it now
let's talk about that let's talk about
that you go to la you got all these
young women right who got all this [ __ ]
done coming to find out they got crazy
amounts of diseases around here
what happened is that actually your body
uh rejects not necessarily rejects but
sometimes your body absorbs the silicone
that's in the breast implant and you're
gonna you know yeah but my my my uh my
fake boobs are
salt water yes but the envelope is
silicone and your body can absorb that
silicone and what happens you can
develop cancer uh fibromyalgia you can
develop a whole bunch of [ __ ]
so
yeah um
don't normalize this [ __ ]
don't look like we can't just in an
effort to be individualistic and be like
oh my god just do whatever you want
we're like watching people and our
families be influenced by this [ __ ]
everyone like pretty much giving
themselves an early grave to look better
uh one to two weeks later i was back in
the gym i'm the first one in the world
who's done this procedure can you stand
up real quick
i mean
and pixie i thought you were
i'll be honest with you guys no sure
recording here all i think and feel is
disgust and it's not even to shame the
woman it's not that
and i think what worries me is like just
the amount of pressure that ladies must
feel to like conform to some of this
stuff and now we're looking at this
we're saying it's ridiculous but now
even ass stuff is normalized
ain't it
if you would have told somebody you
wanted to get your ass done 20 years ago
what people said
you crazy
even though this looks crazy today it's
probably going to be the normal of
tomorrow
that person's gonna age
that person is gonna age
like anybody even though they want don't
wanna age
uh there's gonna be a lot of pressure on
her back there's gonna be a lot of like
the the size of the boobs for the
there's no more support for her core
right it's just a little string so
um
once you're gonna be 50 your face is
probably going to be looking good but
the back is going to be hurting and
stuff like that and everything is going
to when the muscles are not going to
have the same strength and stuff like
that they're going to reduce around 40
and stuff uh
you're going to be suffering okay
but that is
none of my business we don't talk about
that right okay i think i said what i
said in the beginning of the video when
i said
mental health
that's all i said it is but at the end
of the day
what are you gonna do
when they come for you bad boys bad boys
anyways that is it for today's video
let us know what you believe in the
comments below please like and subscribe
hey
it's a papaya we are we are going to be
together for a long time